one in seven people around the world has
some kind of disability
being born without my right hand has
defined who i am over the past 30 years
i was fortunate to grow in the sacred
valley of the incas in couscou peru
surrounded by people who weren't
surprised to see me driving my bike or
probably playing basketball when i was 7
i remember being stunned after i watched
star wars the empire strikes back when
luke's hand gets cut off the same one i
didn't have
but then being twice as stunned when the
medical robots fitted him with a thesis
that could move and feel
from then on no greater purpose leaving
my mind which was to hypothesis like
luca skywalker
this dream led me to study mechatronics
engineering and access the biomechanics
and applied robotics laboratory in
pontifical catholic university of peru
where with a multi-disciplinary team we
developed a myoelectric thesis for long
transradial amputation being me the
pilot user
i was able to move each finger
individually and also we develop a way
in which we get to pass the sensation
from the fingertips into my forearm
using haptic feedback system
since this was a research project we had
enough funding to buy stuff from abroad
so for example the models you get to see
here were all brought by switzerland
this is one of the main reasons why it
will cost at least forty thousand
dollars to make these professes
but 40k is way too much considering that
four out of five people with upper limb
amputation live in development countries
even the twenty five thousand dollars
that caused a robotic thesis imported
from abroad is way too much
in peru that is equivalent to work
full-time on a minimum wage for almost
seven years just to buy the prophesies
never mind pay for your food or your
house
it is often that people get injured
while doing manual labor activities like
farming or metal manufacturing
getting back to work and having access
to money demands a functional hand
it took me time to realize what a huge
privilege i had to study a career that
would help fulfill my dreams
but actually what was preventing me from
developing a solution that was both
affordable and functional
the very first step in order to reducing
the cost was to reduce the number of
motors because they were all imported
and therefore expensive
so we get to arrange occupational focus
groups with our amputee volunteers in
order to identify which gestures they
will use the most and of those how many
we could perform using just a single
motor
the answer was three
pinch
cylindrical
and lateral
this also helps us to reduce the number
of electromyographic sensors too from an
arrangement of eight we pass just to one
in this way between makes in our
mechanical and myoelectric prethesis the
prices will be dramatically low
but material prices matter too
and that's why we choose to 3d print our
professors using mainly plastic from
recycled bottles like the prothesis i am
wearing right now
in order to develop
our prosthesis the process will go like
this first we will use our 3d scan and
our own parametrization software in
order to take the measures of the
amputated area and the other hand of the
user
then we'll recreate the entire set of
fingers the palm and the prothesis
socket in our computational model to
finally 3d print each of those parts
so far in lab bionics we have two types
of prothesis
machi which is a mechanical activation
and pisco with electronic activation
pisco has just 10 percent of an imported
robotic thesis that will come from
abroad
this means that even more working-class
people can access to our technology
for me this has been a path
where i was able to develop this in my
company lab bionics so for example take
franco which now is using his
transradial mackie prosthesis in order
to get back to work with his providers
on the jungle farm he has
i am certain that we are able to be on
the side with technology that is brought
from abroad to our region being sold in
a very expensive way
we have the capacity to develop our own
technology having the necessities of our
people in mind so then people with
disabilities unlimited resources could
live a life again
for me when people our users get back to
work on their places
that look of compassion changed to
astonishment
the same astonishment which i had when i
saw luke skywalker thesis
so this began as a path for myself but
it now belongs to my entire region
would you like to join us
thank you so much